and now here are the nominees for a
performance by an actress in a leading
role
Kate Blanchette tar
Anna dearness blonde
Andrea reisberg to Leslie
Michelle Williams the fablemans
Michelle yo everything everywhere at all
of us
and the Oscar goes to
Michelle yo
all I want
a Child Michelle yeoh studied to become
a ballet dancer and despite her
illustrious career in action films has
no formal training in martial arts
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
for all the little boys and girls who
look like me watching tonight
[Applause]
it's a Beacon of Hope and possibilities
this is proof that dreams dream big and
dreams do come true
and ladies don't let anybody tell you
you are ever past your Prime
you never give up
I wouldn't be standing here tonight
without the Daniels without a24 without
my amazing cast and crew without
everyone who was involved with
everything everywhere all at once
but
oh
I have to dedicate this
to my mom
all the moms in the world because they
are really the superheroes and without
them none of us will be here tonight
[Applause]
she's 84 and I'm taking this home to her
she's watching right now in Malaysia KL
with my family and friends
I love you guys I'm bringing this home
to you
and also to my extended family in Hong
Kong where I started my career
thank you for letting me stand on your
shoulders giving me a leg up so that I
can be here today and to my God children
to my sisters all of them to my brothers
oh God to my family thank you
thank you
thank you to the academy this is history
in the making thank you
[Music]
[Applause]